joining us now with reaction Republican
Senator Lindsey Graham is with us you
know senator why would I ever get in the
midst of I like that
interesting spa ball but you can see now
think about this speaker Pelosi pulls
everyone together you have something to
say to me say it to my face that I don't
right now you gotta give congresswoman
Acacio Cortes credit she went right out
and slugged right back
and I'm like good for her a lot of
courage well Celeste what does this
really mean I think Republicans are more
likely to take the house back the cost
of this breakdown because they're 31
Democrats that whole congressional seats
were President Trump won their
congressional district what does it mean
to these 31 if you cross a OC and the
Feb 4 you're going to get a primary and
if you vote with them you're going to
lose in the general election so the
biggest beneficiary of this will be the
Republican Party in President Trump
because the policies these four people
are pushing or so out of the mainstream
but if you're one of these 31 Democrats
Sean you got to pick between the energy
of the Fab Four and the practicality of
Nancy Pelosi you're in a no-win
situation
maybe I've only been in politics 30
years on radio 30 years we've been here
in the Fox News I'm like the old person
here at Fox I've been here from the
beginning and you can even see it my
hair every night
you know so here's what I'm thinking so
the modern Democratic Party let's see
they want open borders take down the
walls walls are now immoral they won't
want Obama as a president then they want
free health care and you could have no
other choice
Medicare for all then they want higher
taxes then all these 2020 candidates
support the green New Deal everything's
free everything and by the way no oil
gas the lifeblood of our economy no
combustion engine and eventually no cows
and planes why am I thinking that if I'm
Donald Trump I'm a happy guy tonight if
I'm president Trump I'd go to Florida
and show up next November and get
reelected literally mr. president if
you're watching tonight just enjoy this
be quiet because here's what they're
saying they're going to decriminalize
is crossing the border illegally and
once you get here they'll give you free
health care how many people in the world
do you think will take us up on the
offer come to America there's no more
criminal liability and when you get here
we'll give you free health care this is
insane you know it's insane but then you
got this whole other side and somebody
wanted me to ask you a question and I
will ask it which is they're obsessed
with a fifth and sixth Investigation FBI
concluded House intel concluded
bipartisan Senate committee and the
Moller report no conspiracy no collusion
okay that means there's no one to line
crime unlike Hillary underlying crime
with real obstruction subpoenaed emails
bleach pit all that all right so here's
my question so you now have the ability
that they don't have solutions for
America you're gonna run against that
right but you have the ability to bring
in people like Andrew Weissman who we
learned today was responsible for hiring
all the Clinton donors even Clinton's
attorney for robert muller are you gonna
do that I'm gonna let Horowitz do his
job to tell us what happened with the
FISA warrant process then I'm not going
to get in Durham's way who's looking at
putting people in jail but I am going to
explain to the American people that
everybody that was investigating Trump
hated his guts and like Clinton I'm
going to help tell that story but I'm
not gonna do anything into Horowitz
issues his report but we will try to lay
out the facts of the case and make sure
in the future if you apply for a FISA
warrant you have to tell the court oh by
the way the chief informant here hates
the person they're looking on it's not
fair it's not verified so I'll do that
but here's what I want you to understand
the Democratic Party is imploding that's
bad for America their immigration
policies are no more criminal liability
if you coming to the country illegally
you get free health care we're gonna
Bala scheisse and it even if you go to
court and lose you still can't be
deported
now that's insane by the way I've been
down to the border I think about 14
times I'm going to the border tomorrow
to
we'll come back tomorrow we'll update
everybody alright thanks alright senator
grant good to see you thank you